>> Bill: IT’S REMARKABLE.
THANKS, BILL MELUGIN.
NO END IF SIGHT.
>> Dana: LET’S BRING IN ART DEL
CUETO THE PRESIDENT OF THE
NATIONAL BORDER COUNCIL.
UNACCOMPANIED MINORS PICKED UP
AT THE BORDER.
ANOTHER RECORD BROKEN, ART.
>> IT IS OVERWHELMING.
A LOT OF WHAT’S HAPPENING AND
THE CARTELS AND DRUG SMUGGLERS
KNOW ABOUT THIS SO THEY
PURPOSELY SEND BIG GROUPS
ACROSS KNOWING THAT AGENTS WILL
BE DISTRACTED AND KNOWING THAT
AGENTS WILL BE PULLED FROM
CERTAIN AREAS OF THE LINE SO
THEY CAN HAVE TO PROCESS.
ALL THE WHILE THEY ARE BRINGING
THEIR DRUGS ACROSS.
SOMETHING NEEDS TO BE DONE BY
THIS ADMINISTRATION TO STOP IT.
YOU HEAR WORDS OF HEY, THEY’VE
WAVED THE WHITE FLAG.
FROM SPEAKING TO AGENTS ON THE
GROUND NONE OF THE AGENTS OUT
THERE ARE WAVING THE WHITE
FLAGS.
WE ARE AMERICANS AND WE WON’T
GIVE UP OUR BORDER.
THEY ARE OUT THERE DOING A JOB
AND WILL CONTINUE TO DO THE JOB.
IT IS VERY FRUSTRATING WHEN YOU
HAVE THE AGENCY HEADS AND
ADMINISTRATION THAT IS NOT
BACKING THEM UP RIGHT NOW.
>> Dana: WE TALKED ABOUT RECORD
NUMBERS.
TODAY IS AUGUST 3.
LISTEN TO WHAT VICE PRESIDENT
KAMALA HARRIS SAID ON JUNE 25th.
>> PROGRESS.
WE AREN’T EXACTLY WHERE WE WANT
TO BE YET BUT WE’VE SEEN
EXTREME PROGRESS OVER THE LAST
FEW MONTHS BECAUSE OF HIS
DEDICATION AND HIS EFFORTS.
>> Dana: HAS THERE BEEN
PROGRESS?
>> IF WHAT THEY MEAN BY
PROGRESS IS ALLOWING PEOPLE TO
ENTER AND BREAK OUR LAWS THEN I
GUESS IN THEIR EYES THAT’S
PROGRESS.
I DON’T WARE IF YOU’RE ON THE
LEFT OR RIGHT SIDE OF THE AISLE
WE DESERVE TO BE SAFE IN OUR
HOMES AND NO DIFFERENCE IN OUR
NATION’S BORDER.
RIGHT NOW IT’S HORRIFIC WITH
THESE INDIVIDUALS COMING ACROSS
AND YOU LOOK AT THE NUMBERS OF
APPREHENSIONS.
WHAT YOU HAVE TO LOOK AT IS
THOSE APPREHENSIONS ARE BEING
RELEASED INTO THE UNITED STATES.
THEN YOU HAVE THE COVID TALK.
MANY TIMES INDIVIDUALS BEING
ARRESTED GET SENT TO OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS AND DETENTION
FACILITIES.
LATER AFTER THEY’VE BEEN THERE
FOR A WHILE AGENTS GET THE CALL
AND SAY HEY, SO AND SO THAT YOU
ARRESTED SEVERAL DAYS AGO ENDED
UP BEING POSITIVE FOR COVID.
SO IT IS A DOMINO EFFECT THAT
THERE IS NO END IN SIGHT RIGHT
NOW UNLESS YOU GO BACK TO THE
POLICIES THAT WORKED UNDER THE
LAST ADMINISTRATION, THE REMAIN
IN MEXICO WAS A HUMANE WAY TO
DO THINGS BECAUSE IT FAST
TRACKED THOSE THAT HAD REAL
ASYLUM CLAIMS AND DISCOURAGED
ALL THE PEOPLE THAT ARE COMING
ACROSS RIGHT NOW FINDING THOSE
LOOPHOLES IN OUR IMMIGRATION
SYSTEM.
>> Dana: THE POINT ABOUT COVID
CASES IN THE RIO GRANDE VALLEY,
135 DETAINEES TESTED POSITIVE
FOR THE FIRST TWO WEEKS OF JULY.
900% INCREASE COMPARED TO
PREVIOUS 14 MONTHS AND NOW WITH
THE DELTA VARIANT YOU CAN
IMAGINE THAT IS GOING TO BE
EVEN HIGHER.
A LOT TO DEAL WITH HERE, ART.